اعتقدت بالتأكيد أنني لم
ألمس يدي أبدًا، فهما
معًا
حطاب سابق في مانهاتن وشقيقته ميشيل بينيت
التي أصبحت الآن مقدمة الرعاية له، لقد شاهدت
حياتهم تتغير بسرعة عندما كان
كيث يبلغ من العمر 41 عامًا، وهو يغطس بطريق الخطأ في
بركة ضحلة  في مونتوك، لم أتعرض لكسر في
قاع حوض السباحة، وأصبت بالشلل
من الصدر إلى الأسفل،
وقع الحادث في يوليو من عام 2020،
يقول كيث إنه توقف عن التحدث مع
أصدقائه لمدة عام ونصف، لقد
شعرت بالحرج من حدوث ذلك  لقد
دفعني للانضمام إلى دراسة باستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي لاستعادة
الحركة الجسدية واللمس من خلال
معاهد فاينشتاين التابعة لـ Northwell Health
من الأبحاث الطبية، وكان التحدي يتمثل في
الحصول على هذه
الأقطاب الكهربائية الصغيرة والهشة الصغيرة والمئات منها التي تم
تركيبها على هذه الرقائق الخمس التي
تستهدف بدقة  مناطق الدماغ
المسؤولة عن الشعور بأطراف
أصابعه وتحريك يده،
أنشأ الأطباء نموذجًا ثلاثي الأبعاد لدماغ كيث
للتدرب عليه، وقد نجحت الجراحة التي استغرقت 15 ساعة
في مارس في فتح
وإغلاق يده، وهو ما كان قادرًا
على فعله  ماذا كان الأمر
رائعًا، كان أمرًا لا يصدق، لم أستطع أن أصدق أنه
كان يحدث،
سجل الأطباء تلك الجراحة، هذه هي
الحالة الأولى من هذا النوع في العالم، يمكنه
رفع يده إلى أعلى ولكنه يريد أن يفعل
المزيد
مثل مسح دموعه.
أنا مكان أفضل الآن حيث
بدأ هذا لأول مرة